for a long time there have been women
doing uh in really interesting things
and invention and Building Things and
creating things and and inventing whole
genres
um in electronic music and Electro
acoustic music and so on and so forth
but um I think that the level that that
they're finally getting recognized for
it and included and also more of them
are doing it because more of them are
feeling welcome when I first started
doing this work if I was ever on a
compilation of artists doing electronic
music or Electro acoustic compositions
or whatever
I would all I'd be the only woman on it
it would be me and a bunch of guys I was
actually on an event in San Francisco
that was curated by this guy who had
picked a bunch of us out who had done
this performance Marathon year after
year and it turned out that everyone was
a woman and it was a total accident he
didn't do it on purpose it was just we
were happen to be this stalwart people
who like had been on that festival and
been faithful to it and come back and
and had continued doing our work and and
so when he noticed this he suddenly
wanted to give that evening a name like
ladies you know women's this or that and
we were like do you call it men's night
when it's all men which it usually is
you know and he was like oh I guess we
don't and I said well then can you like
not call this that and just like let
people let people notice and find it
interesting if they notice or maybe not
notice you know but you know you didn't
select us because of our gender so let's
not title the evening
to do with our gender